okay everybody sit down good afternoon
all you Book Festival folks I'm Tom
Sherwood from NBC 4 here in Washington
and the public radio wamu Kojo Nnamdi
show on Fridays thank you for being here
you're welcome your cell phones are not
but always say don't turn it off if it
rings we just want you to put it on
speakerphone so we'll know who's calling
you and by the way this is your legal
warning
your presence here is your permission to
be videotaped and quoted and
misrepresented on social media now
finding your way around this huge
Convention Center it opened in 2003 can
be daunting going up and down floors in
one room and then another finding food
finding the bathrooms lining up for
autographs you might say being here
today is quote enjoyably exhaustive
enjoyably exhaustive well that's the
high praise a New York Times Review gave
to Douglas Brinkley's latest book on
American politics and culture rightful
heritage Franklin D Roosevelt in the
land of America I incidentally will not
be exhaustive in this nearly two dozen
books over 25 years
historian Brinkley know related to that
other guy has ReWalk tanned retraced so
many elements of America our wars our
politics our our industry our natural
disaster called Katrina the light the
rice professor especially has been
honored for his attention to Franklin D
Roosevelt and Teddy Roosevelt so it's
fitting in this year the 100th
anniversary of the National Park Service
and not far from the FDR memorial and
the Potomac River Island named in Teddy
Roosevelt's honor Douglas Brinkley can
help us understand
in America and here in the nation's
capital today as we celebrate this Book
Festival as we open the new
african-american museum on the National
Mall and yes as we steel ourselves for
Monday night's not football but
presidential debate in this difficult
campaign year in these next few minutes
maybe Douglas Brinkley can offer insight
and hope and this still forming sweet
land of liberty please everyone welcome
Douglas Brinkley
it is wonderful to be introduced by Tom
who has a straw Denari voice it's and
I'm trying to try to modulate mine I'm
used to talking loud because I'm a Rice
University professor and you have to
project without microphones but I'm here
to talk about Franklin D Roosevelt and
the national parks FDR we all know as it
was called the squire of of Hyde Park he
was born in 1882 in the Hudson River
Valley and his whole life the Hudson
became his sanctified landscape it's the
place that he most loved he was born on
Hyde Park on the Hudson he lived in the
same home where he was born all of his
life and he's buried at Hyde Park
it's our nation's first presidential
library and he would always find
strength from that River 315 miles going
from the high Adirondack Mountains
coming into New York City it is a
spectacular River and when he was born
in 1882 his family was part of keeping
the Hudson beautiful movement today we
call it the scenic Hudson movement but
everybody was starting to look at
resources being destroyed in the East
Coast on this is pre when he's born the
idea of the week sacra he's saved
national forests in the East and
everybody was clear-cutting
and the river was getting polluted and
fish stocks were dying and so Franklin
Roosevelt's father became very popular
and in local conservation on the Hudson
and they're also the number one book
writer I'm at a Book Festival if you
were alive in 1880s 1890s 1900 the big
writer was John Burroughs the great
naturalist who sanctified the Catskills
and so FDR grew up conservation as we
call today was part of his life script
most famously because Theodore Roosevelt
his fifth cousin who he
nevertheless called uncle Teddy your
uncle Theodore he as you know is
synonymous with the conservation
movement Theodore Roosevelt and TR
always enjoyed looking at from New York
City but looking west FDR was more about
the oceans and the rivers but by the
time
Franklin Roosevelt goes to college to
Harvard and you need to know if you want
to understand anything at all about
Franklin Roosevelt you have to study
Theodore Roosevelt there they all he
took as a model you know uncle
Theodore's life as curt of a script so
Theodore Roosevelt had been the head of
the Forrest Fish and Game Commission in
New York State FDR becomes the head of
it Theodore Roosevelt was assistant
secretary of the Navy FDR assistant
secretary of the Navy Theodore Roosevelt
was governor of New York FDR was the
governor of New York Theodore Roosevelt
loved big Navy FDR loved big Navy
Theodore Roosevelt loved conservation in
the natural resources and heirlooms of
America FDR loved all of those Theodore
Roosevelt had a niece named Eleanor
Roosevelt in FDR married er you cannot
deal with all the revolution of the New
Deal years in conservation and the
Civilian Conservation Corps in the like
which i'ma talk about them in a minute
without thinking about TR but Theodore
Roosevelt created two mechanisms as
president guys that you know all
national parks were here celebrating the
system was born under the Organic Act in
1916 by Woodrow Wilson but that organic
act for an a national park it has to go
through Congress
so Theodore Roosevelt as president would
do that from 1901 to 1909 he push
through crater lake in Oregon
Mesa Verde in Colorado Wind Cave in
South Dakota and others but Theodore
Roosevelt as president created two
mechanisms which all presidents followed
have used and one is called national
monuments and the idea is built on the
antiquities Act of nineteen Oh
six the antiquities Act was an elastic
piece of legislation but said for
scientific reasons mainly meant for
archeological digs of prehistoric
dinosaur bones and for Native American
relics that a president could declare a
ward off an area think about like a
murder site with the yellow piece of
plastic you know going around a hunk of
land that could be by executive order
saved and the reason this antiquities
Act of 1906 went into play is the
Europeans were robbing our Western sites
they recognized the importance of the
Navajo and that Patchi and the plain
Indians and they were stealing things
and they were stealing our dinosaur
bones so this gets passed on Congress
well Theodore Roosevelt ends up going to
Yellowstone with John burrows the great
naturalist then he goes to the Grand
Canyon and TR stands out that Canyon
looks out over the divine abyss and says
do not touch it God has made it you will
only Mar it leave the Grand Canyon alone
and Congress and Senate starts moving to
perhaps mine it for zinc of Estes and
copper and Theodore Roosevelt then uses
the executive order meant for smaller
parcels for over 600,000 acres and now
it's over a a million acres today or
else the Grand Canyon would have been
lost and TR would do that to save the
redwoods and Muir Woods he would do that
you know to save Devils Tower Wyoming
so that lives on and after due to
Theodore Roosevelt Brock Obama's is now
the president that assigned more
national monuments than any other I just
wrote a piece about a week ago in The
New York Times about it secondly the a
hundred years ago women here would have
worn a bonnet with ornamental feathers
to hear me speak you may not think you
would have you may have but you would
have
and these would have been feathers of an
Egret or a heron
nothing calls for federal action more
than bird protection you could not have
a liberal Connecticut Audubon Society
that's protecting the birds to have them
fly to Florida and be slaughtered
willy-nilly birds no no boundaries so it
demanded federal attention if we were
going to save species for extinction and
Theodore Roosevelt goes to Pelican
island Florida a bird rookery where
these guys were coming with guns and
gunning all the birds and plucking the
feathers and then stealing the eggs and
he says I so declare it a federal bird
reservation and he does that 51 times
saving the albatross of Hawaii saving
parts of Alaska the size of West
Virginia in giving these areas to
wildlife those 51 are later expanded by
dozens to over a hundred to two hundred
by FDR and it's franklin roosevelt
building on TRS bird reservations that
creates in 1940 today's US Fish and
Wildlife you all here in the audience
own over 550 national wildlife refuges
because of TR starting it in FDR moving
on it and for those national monuments I
just mentioned when you can't get up a
piece of land saved through Congress you
do the executive orders so many places
that we all celebrate in this country
Capitol Reef and Utah a great National
Park
FDR creates it as a monument today it's
a park channel islands off of Santa
Barbara area in in Ventura California
gorgeous Islands the Galapagus of
America FDR saves it as a National
Monument today it's a park the Olympics
National Forest up there beautiful rain
forests in Washington State FDR went
there and saw how people were recklessly
clear cutting the land and Franklin
Roosevelt said whoever
did that I hope they're roasting in hell
and he pushes through the creation of
our Olympic National Park so but keep in
mind the monuments and wildlife refuges
are both Roosevelt's but FDR takes it to
a new level
now the turning point for Franklin
Roosevelt I think as a true
conservationist to match and perhaps
supersede Theodore is occurs in 1921 FDR
is goes in he loses we're dealing an
election right now in 1920 it was the it
was Warren Harding beat Cox and
Roosevelt FDR was the VP in 1920 the
Democrats lose FDR had no job he had
been assistant secretary of the Navy he
was just now the losing DP candidate and
he asked himself what would Theodore
Roosevelt have done and the answer was
he worked for the Boy Scouts of Greater
New York TR was the great pusher of the
Boy Scouts the godfather of it and now
Franklin Roosevelt organizes the Boy
Scouts of Greater New York to go to Bear
Mountain State Park on the Hudson River
in his backyard up there and bring all
these inner-city kids to do horseshoes
and archery and fishing and enjoy the
bounties of nature and the Hudson and
unfortunately he went swimming with
these Boy Scouts and we think they're
contracted the polio virus and he didn't
manifest itself till he got to
Campobello New Brunswick and while he
was there he went to bed he had a sweats
he didn't feel well and he woke up with
no feeling in the lower half of his body
the man you all know for saying we have
nothing to fear but fear itself you know
you know was an utter fear and panic in
terror Eleanor Roosevelt became his
Florence Nightingale it was very
generous of her because she had found
love letters from Lucy Mercer
that FDR was having an affair she put
all that aside and he goes back to Hyde
Park on the Hudson to to heal and nobody
wants to see him because to hug somebody
with polio would have been a fear of you
would have contracted it so all these
friends mr. good-looking mr. assistant
secretary of the Navy mr. I was just the
VP nominee is now a pariah and he found
solace on the Hudson among the squirrels
and the birds FDR was a lifelong
ornithologist and then he says what did
Theodore Roosevelt do in his crisis
Theodore Roosevelt's big crisis guys was
not when he was the rough Wyatt Rider
in 1898 in the spanish-american war
Theodore Roosevelt's big crisis wasn't
when he got shot in 1912 in Milwaukee
when he was delivering a speech for the
bull moose party Theodore Roosevelt's
huge crisis came when he was a young man
on the same day Valentine's Day he TR
lost his mother in the same house his
mother with bright disease collapsed
kidneys and his wife died giving
childbirth he lost his mom and his wife
on the same day Theodore Roosevelt we as
scholars read people's mail for a living
and there's nothing more moving than
seeing the giant X that TR puts in his
diary and says the light's gone out of
my life forever what does he do when
he's depressed losing a mother and wife
he got lost in the wild he went to North
Dakota the Dakota Territory Medora the
Badlands when looking for grizzly and
Buffalo in fact he starts the modern
endangered species movement of
protection of a North American animal
life when he kills the Buffalo Theodore
Roosevelt up there and then realizes
they're all disappearing and he creates
a Boone and Crockett Club to save them
so FDR gets lost in the wilderness but
he goes to the Everglades in Everglades
is a national park that Franklin
Roosevelt creates but he goes in the
Everglade
and the whole to Florida Keys and goes
boating and he thinks that water will
help him with the polio and he right
he's down there with an ornithologist
friend in the 1920s writing down all of
the different species he sees he's
bird-watching in trying to heal in
nature the way TR had done in the
Badlands he comes back from these
Florida trips and buys Warm Springs
Georgia a resort of natural thermal
pools in Georgia Meriwether County you
can go there now and he creates a resort
for people with polio living in nature
among the trees and the rest and that's
his business FDR and he becomes the
leader of the State Park movement do you
guys realized FDR in the 20s is pushing
state parks but by the time he's
president the New Deal will Cray create
over eight hundred state parks in the
United States states didn't even have
state parks into FDR's New Deal work
forces came and built them including
Texas where I live in Austin and I teach
in at Rice in Houston right now and he
then decides while trying to get back
into politics FDR and he trains to give
a speech at Madison Square Gardens for
Al Smith the big big shot in New York
and his training isn't practicing his
verbage it's learning how to lean on one
son and move his hips in a very painful
motion to get to the podium in everybody
at Madison Square Gardens when FDR came
out held their breath first off
everybody thought he was done with
politics he was too sick here you're
just praying he doesn't fall then he got
to the podium and gave an amazing speech
and got a thunderous standing ovation
off the charts for it went on almost an
hour next day's New York Times says move
over al Smith FDR's the man in he's the
new East the hot guy in politics now and
from that resurrection
FDR runs for governor in 1928 of New
York and then governor in 1930 and he
wins both and his big program is
planting trees soil conservation
reforestation because he was a rural
upstate New York politician FDR not a
New York City guy I've read letters
Franklin Roosevelt would write please do
not say I'm from New York City his
constituents were apple growers and and
people people growing orchids and
lumbers and the Catskills and fishermen
and he was a rural politician and he he
worked as governor to pay men with no
jobs unemployed homeless essentially a
dollar a day to start tree planting in
building state parks in restocking lakes
and ponds Franklin Roosevelt's whole
calling card was conservation as
governor so when you cut to 1932 when he
gives the New Deal speech and you cut to
Franklin Roosevelt saying we're gonna
put people to work he in his own mind
creates the Civilian Conservation Corps
and not only does he beat Herbert Hoover
but at his famous inaugural weeks later
he announces his pet New Deal program
the CCC the CCC from 1933 to 1942 plants
around 3 billion trees across the United
States because these and these are done
by unemployed men from somebody from
Newark New Jersey who suddenly finds
himself in Zion National Park in Utah or
somebody you know from a poor
neighborhood of Philadelphia suddenly on
the New Mexico Arizona border it was
remarkable and it worked and because the
big mistake we make is thinking about
the Great Depression being Wall Street
collapse in the financial markets and
bank foreclosures we had destroyed the
land of America we had done the great
plow up in the Midwest and chopped all
the trees we had soil erosion
and made problems environmental disaster
of the Dust Bowl in the 1930s we had
drain wetlands we had drained swamps and
so it became a absolute landscape of
America that was dying and he takes it
over and he is able to as president take
to your conservation to a new level do
you want to now committed Franklin
Roosevelt is to our parks in the love of
America
Franklin Roosevelt at the time of Pearl
Harbor pearl this is a big moment of
Pearl Harbor he gets a letter from
Rosalie edge with his great Harold Ickes
the best interior secretary in American
history and edge is a conservation
environmental activists from New York
and she says dear mr. president the
trumpeter swan is going to go extinct
because you have built the 10th Mountain
Division a training facility for ski
troopers and Henry's Lake Idaho and it
happens to be that area the water
doesn't freeze over so the trumpeters
spend their winters there instead of
migrating and if you don't do something
trumpeters can go extinct
well the 10th Mountain Division facility
costs like twenty four million dollars
it was training our soldiers to go fight
in Italy in Germany and in Europe and
FDR writes a moving letter to his
Secretary of Defense Henry K Stimpson
dear Henry I've now found out about the
flap between the US Army and the
trumpeters I've looked into it in the
verdict in is in I side with the
trumpeters the 10th Mountain Division
must rhiness sincerely Franklin D
Roosevelt why at the time of Pearl
Harbor would he do that well who here
doesn't want to save trumpeter swans a
species okay but this is the big
crucible because he is telling the War
Department and he'd write letters like
that to Agriculture Department into
every division in government our public
lands are an inheritance we are not
going to to destroy our national forests
in parts in monuments and state parks by
going in
for win the war these are what we're
fighting for our public land system is
what America is about it's our heritage
hence why I call my book rightful
heritage that's what he would call all
of these recreation places and special
places we have he did something similar
to save the whooping crane from
extinction by signing an executive order
creating Aransas National Wildlife
Refuge in Texas on national park skies
June 6 1944 d-day do you realize on
d-day here in Washington Franklin
Roosevelt when all the news was coming
wouldn't cancel a meeting about Big Bend
National Park and he creates takes the
land deed for it on d-day with Amon
Carter and people from Fort Worth
pictures on d-day with maps that he's
picking out where the roads and how one
could bring visitors to Big Bend he goes
to Glacier National Park and makes with
him set up radio shop there so he could
stand with the CCC and say there is
nothing more American than our national
parks in 1937 Franklin and what and he
traveled and crated Cape Hatteras our
nation's first national seashore
creating a whole new designation John F
Kennedy was very keen on that and that's
why Kennedy saved Cape Cod National
Seashore
South Padre Island in Texas point raised
in California but little-known is
Roosevelt would go all over on his
yachts and on Navy ships and he
disappeared on the eve really of world
war ii in the late 1930s to go disappear
into the Galapagos Islands FDR went for
weeks doing floral and fauna collections
for the Smithsonian Institute looking
for new species of burrowing shrimp and
fish because this love of a biology and
conservation is in the Roosevelt's
bloodstream I will end by telling you
two quick things his whatever Franklin
Roosevelt put put on a form occupation
he would write tree farmer he ran tree
plantations at Warm Springs Georgia and
on the Hudson if you go to his home you
will see the forest he planted all that
was when he would bring Churchill to
Hyde Park he was showing off the the
bars that he planted and how he was a
scientific Forester it meant everything
to him
he had learned inside out about soil
conservation FDR thought that
deforestation the killing of trees meant
utter poverty so much so that the time
of terror on conference he went over and
of course was in the Middle East and he
comes home and writes a personal letter
to the Shah of Iran and to the king of
Saudi Arabia saying well I've been to
your part of the world now and I've got
to tell you you've got a forestry
problem and I'm personally willing to
loan my time pro bono to help you fix it
do not feel bad we had this problem out
of we have you know the Dust Bowl and
we're we we know some of it but I
figured out ways to help do you realize
that in 1945 right before his death
April 1245 Franklin D Roosevelt was
working with Gifford Pinchot the chief
Forester for Theodore Roosevelt who's
now in his 80s had a couple of heart
attacks was going to be dead soon and
they couldn't they could inspire
together to make the founding of the
United Nations a key principle was going
to be conservation as a basis of
permanent peace and FDR was moving to
have sharing of natural resources to
have global pollution laws to have ways
that we had an international forestry
and wildlife protection laws everybody
at Warren State Department went running
they would ignore him when the few times
I ever saw FDR was angry when he wrote a
letter and was telling his State
Department I am serious about this
Conservation is going to be a big part
of the UN we're gonna do global
conservation right off the bat when he
died a lot of this this energy of
conservation died with the Truman
administration the Truman crowd and no
interest but in the end
our heritage in the United States some
national parks like the Smokies the
Everglades on great roads like the Blue
Ridge Parkway and Natchez Trace a
magical parks like Mammoth Cave in
Kentucky Isle Royale and Michigan I can
go on and on and on we owe it to
Franklin D Roosevelt for at her time of
crisis and the Great Depression of World
War one reminded us that stewardship of
our national resources was one of what
was one of if not the most important
thing that we can do great countries
take care of their landscapes and
Franklin Roosevelt in my mind along with
TR was one of the two great conservation
presidents thank you
thank you
I have a comment before I ask my
question we just came back from Hyde
Park and you know that across the Hudson
there is this walking bridge called the
FDR bridge and I thought it was because
you know he and Eleanor came from that
area but now you're saying maybe it was
in tribute to the fact that this is the
only bridge you can people can walk no
carts yes yes that's part of why they've
done that but across the river from Hyde
Park is home John Burroughs this he's
like John Muir John Burroughs he's if
we're a book crowd here look up and read
about John Burroughs he's very under
sung he lived directly across the street
on the Hudson then FDR would always have
to go on the other side of the Hudson
and that bridge is a way to kind of
connect that region now let me ask you a
technical question going back to the
relationship between Teddy and Franklin
okay you know when Teddy was police
chief whatever he would walk in the
streets with newspaper people and he
knew to use the newspapers as a vehicle
to communicate and you know many years
later this guy Franklin Roosevelt this
enhanced that to the radio so that was a
big big change well you're absolutely
right and TR was a genius at
manipulating cartoonist I mean the teddy
bear toy grew out of his going on a bear
hunt and he wouldn't shoot the bear in
Mississippi and it became a symbol for
fair chase hunting and conservation of
Theodore Roosevelt FDR used radio so
effectively to bring that voice because
he was incapacitated unable to walk but
what's not known about Franklin is he
trained his upper body was amazingly
strong and he would go fishing all over
he became a big buff on marine
conservation so he would pull in Silver
King's giant tarpon and go on these
marine expeditions because that was a
way for him to get outdoor recreation
and it was also a way not to have the
press come with him because his health
was deeply precarious at times so if he
could get out at sea and go to the drive
tortugas which he saved in Florida FDR
and spend time there whenever he'd see a
place that he liked he'd sign in an
executive order and save it it's really
quite remarkable now let me get to the
point the the today with the press you
see Trump you see others saying as
president I would do this I would do
this a key point that when Roosevelt
Franklin Rose will come in the office he
used the term let's try it try it try it
did he inherit that from to you I never
quote Stalin in public but I'm gonna do
it for just for you guys
but Stalin used to say after negotiating
with Churchill and FDR Churchill will
work with you and then try to sneak his
hand in your pocket to steal a coin
FDR smiles and greets you jams both
hands in and pulls out everything all at
once it's very true FDR love so all of
these you know people when he try to
pack the Supreme Court for example
people were also in all is he in 1937
people were turning in FDR he was
signing executive orders left and right
saving wild places because nobody knew
what was going on then he got revenge on
that by picking William O Douglas the
most environmental conservation driven
person of the 60s and 70s who saved the
CNO canal incidentally here and and it's
and he put him to the Supreme Court also
should tell you the mall here that we're
honoring at the National Book Festival
that's FDR months after he becomes
president he grabs all of the monuments
the mall the White House and puts it
into interior department they used to be
run by other War Department Agriculture
he made it he built today's interior
department Franklin Roosevelt and Harold
Ickes and and now our National Park
Service keeps growing and that's what
FDR wanted the history to be part of it
not just Yellowstone's and Yosemite
'he's so barack obama's just signed an
executive order to do stone
for LGBT history he just did Obama did
Cesar Chavez in California for Latino
history he just did Harriet Tubman in
Maryland for Underground Railroad he's
opening up the narrative as they're
saying of American history Obama's been
great at that
FDR's the one who started that ability
to save labor strike places or something
that wasn't you know it might be
controversial and save those as part of
our national heritage
thank you yes sir I've had a chance to
read both your books on Theodore
Roosevelt and Franklin Roosevelt thank
you they are absolutely magnificent in
reading them and listening to you today
you know I observed that we've got one
great Republican president and one great
Democratic president and for a long
period of time conservation and the
environmental movement wasn't really a
partisan issue now it's a very deeply
partisan issue
what happened amazing question and it
used to be Republican Party got into
conservation all the time many of the
heroes including the Rockefeller family
who incidentally who didst Laurance
Rockefeller and John D jr. and the like
who did so much for it Ronald Reagan
created over 50 wilderness areas that's
roadless areas of pristine wilderness
reagan did that today you have a
Republican Party that is running on oil
gas oil gas drill baby drill open open
open end day there's a backlash against
the federal government particularly in
the West in Alaska that so it puts
things at loggerheads so if you're a
Republican in the Senate today being a
conservationist is very very hard the
turning point in my mind was when the
word invite conservation was replaced by
environmental George McGovern told me
before he died I wish we would have just
kept the word conservation because I it
sounds like conservative and I could
push things through in the Senate but
once that word environment came it was
tied up too
sixties cultural Wars of hippies and
tree huggers and marijuana and you know
and it became seen as like a left issue
in out of the 60s and we haven't fully
recovered with that however there are
republican congressmen like congressman
Simpson from Idaho who recently just
saved a boulder white clouds as a
wilderness area and there are a few very
Lamar Alexander of Tennessee has gotten
into the conservation story quite a bit
but unfortunately like so much in our
culture it's become partisan and I'm
hoping that eventually it'll come back
because if I go to a group of
conservatives Republicans somewhere and
talk about saving the local lake or
river they love me cause I'm praising
local sites and we want it clean we want
our kids to fish and hunt we but if I
started dropping the e bomb
environmental you lose half your
audience right now so we've got it kind
of it a lot of it might be on where the
way we repackage how we speak about it
some but it's a frustration Barry
Goldwater was a pretty good
conservationist actually mr. Brinkley
I've read your book on Teddy Roosevelt
and looking forward to the book on FDR
huge fan really appreciated your lecture
today I wanted to ask a question or
maybe get your thoughts on an issue that
is related to the last question in the
course of your lecture and in your books
you describe the way the presidents use
their authority to create and conserve
these natural areas but it seems that
overwhelmingly they relied upon the
power of executive orders or unilateral
executive branch authority and
particularly relying I think that was on
the antiquities Act which authorizes the
President to apply that Authority
without consulting or getting the
approval of Congress and it's my amateur
observation that over the decades the
fact that these conservation efforts
took place through presidential
authority in many instances bypassing
local congressional delegations without
seeking the support of Congress not
needing the support of Congress
created a situation that has presented
challenges in the modern era and I
recognized that the president's needed
to do what they needed to do and I
certainly approve of what they did I
love the result but we have we in your
view created something of a literalist
problem in terms of other is its
backlash of this assertion of federal if
I was to the national monuments to keep
it on FB our little FDR for example in
the middle of World War two was gifted
Jackson Hole Wyoming and wrote the
Rockefellers bought all this land up now
they're giving it to him FDR signs an
executive order saying we're going to
create the Grand T save the Grand Tetons
Jackson Hole you should read what
happened to FDR your Hitler your land
grabbing the federal government -
there's nobody today that doesn't want
Jackson Hole protected like FDR did they
were in California and Joshua Tree
that's them that's FDR's a woman named
Ravana Hamilton Hoyt was trying to get
it as a park through Congress said it's
desert deserts a wasteland nobody wants
it and she was a botanist and saying no
these Joshua trees are amazing meanwhile
the kids that go out to Burning Man used
to go out on the desert and pour
gasoline and burn the Joshua's because
they shoot up like a torch into the
night and they would look for the
biggest and they burned them all so she
eventually gets to FDR and says can you
save it and he looks at her plan and
says I'll save a million acres and she
said well the railroads have interests
there and at local miners he said
lawyers we'll figure it out later
we're gonna do it she was stunned she
got what she wanted from him in Kings
Canyon another National Park of FDR's in
California it took the young unknown
photographer named Ansel Adams took
these photos and Eleanor Roosevelt said
if you want my husband to save something
bring the photos he's a sucker for will
Adams photos so he ended up seeing these
in push to be saved Kings Canyon but at
er didn't like that was gonna be
roadless no roads go and he said I'm
never gonna be able to go see it that
area because if they're not roads and
visitor lookouts I won't be able to go
because of my thing but he did it any
rate because it in you you just have to
have a strong president do it or else or
that you know I've been for example to
Haiti you want to fly over Hispaniola
look at Dominican Republic with forests
in Haiti deforested I need you all to
believe that in the 1930s and early 40s
our country was in genuinely awful shape
and swamps Artic Tundra deserts were not
considered ecosystems worth saving - now
these places are the big economic
engines Joshua Tree doesn't know what to
do with visitors it's so overcrowded so
there the antiquities Act gives
presidents a mechanism in George W Bush
signed a giant one out on the Hawaii for
a marine area Calvin Coolidge used to
sign them all the time I'm just
suggesting it's that has become
bipartisan monuments presidents will do
them but Obama just did the Maine woods
cotton a couple of weeks ago and they're
angry and main about it even though the
land was gifted by Roxane Quimby who
founded Burt's Bees the women's product
she became the biggest landowner in
Maine said I'll not only give you the
land to the federal government as a park
but I'll also endow it with twenty
million dollars and the Conservatives of
Maine don't want it they see it as
federal government intrusion into their
lives so the good news here and all I
think I better end the national parks on
their centennial right now are
spectacular we need to love them or
visit them they really are this great
gift and we owe both Theodore and
Franklin Roosevelt a huge bit of credit
for being visionaries of making our
country something special without it we
would be strip malls and super highways
but by saving all these wild places it's
kept the the
essential spirit of America in my mind
alive thank you
[Applause]